Put down that sparkling water, those bubbles
might ruin your smile.
Hi guys, Crystal here for DNews
Not all bubbly water is created equal: sparkling
is pure carbonated water, club soda has added
salts, tonic water can contain sugar, and
many flavored mineral waters contain additional
acids, salt, and sugar.
So are they all bad for you?
How unhealthy can water be?
In the past few years sales of carbonated
water products has doubled in the US and for
those of us that are drinking at least a bottle
of fizzy water a day, the internet has concerns
that those delightful bubbles are leaching
calcium out of our bones, contributing to
tooth decay, and even make us gain weight
. Now, I’m sure that anyone who has the
self awareness to acknowledge a habit that
isn’t exactly performed in moderation has
probably at some point asked themselves the
question: “how bad is this?”
Well, as usual science says…
“It depends”
When a liquid beverage contains bubbles it’s
usually the result of carbonation.
In alcoholic beverages that carbonation is
a natural byproduct of fermentation, but in
water, it’s usually just carbon dioxide
gas some chemist forced to dissolve in water
using low temperature and high pressure.
When this happens, it makes my favorite molecule:
carbonic acid, H2CO3!
That hissing sound you hear when you open
a new bottle of sparkling water is the release
of pressure that keeps the gas dissolved and
the delightful effervescence you drink is
the result of carbonic acid rushing to a new
equilibrium by decomposing into carbon dioxide
(g) and water (l).
Now, we know acidic foods erode tooth enamel,
so if carbonation comes from acid, how bad
is that for our teeth?
Well, flavored carbonated waters have the
mild acidity of a fruit juice and they are
not nearly as corrosive as acidic soft drinks
(you may call them pop or colas).
A study in the Journal of Oral Rehabilitation
goes as far to suggest that sparkling water
can be considered a “safe alternative”
to sugared soft drinks, which have pH values
that come close to the digestive levels of
stomach acid!
It has also been thought that carbonic acid
in fizzy drinks was contributing to loss of
bone calcium and increased risk for osteoporosis
but recently it was shown that the caffeine
and phosphoric acids found in colas could
be the real culprit.
In fact, some mineral waters that contain
calcium salts could be considered good for
your bones!
Carbonation has been blamed for causing a
variety of complaints including irritable
bowel syndrome (IBS) and weight gain.
In most cases it is the additives like mineral
salts, flavorings, and sugars that are to
blame for the reported adverse effects.
But IBS is one of the few cases where the
bubbles truly are the culprit.
Even so, carbonation can exacerbate IBS, it
doesn’t cause the disease.
So, sugared drinks like sodas are still bad
for you, carbonated water is a healthier alternative
to soft drinks but flat water is still better,
and you should read the label of your bubbly
beverage before you check out at the grocery
store.
Also, remember: carbonic acid is kind of like
that one friend in your social group, unstable
but innocuous.
And only unhealthy when other elements are
added to the mix.
Now that you know how to be an informed seltzer
drinker, watch this video by Trace about why
we like those bubbles so very much.
It isn’t what you’d think.
Guys, do you
have any science questions?
What should we look into next?
Tell us in the comments, subscribe for more
DNews and thanks for watching!